after the rains the cleanup and a
rethink on how to adapt to a changing
climate
the worst affected places were in
low-lying areas south of seoul's han
river
it's home to the glitzy gangnam district
made famous in the hit gangnam style
[Music]
but it's also the location for poorer
housing including half basement
apartments prone to flooding resident
hain sick tries to salvage what he can
from his home
when the rains came he and his family
were forced to evacuate seeking shelter
in a nearby park
i have to throw away all my possessions
even my dishes it rained so much this
time it was a disaster
the plight of such residents was
highlighted in the oscar-winning movie
parasite about a fictional family living
a subterranean existence
but it's the reality for many in a city
with sky-high property prices
it's different from the wealthy places
we live in the smaller streets where the
government doesn't pay attention to us
south korea's president yun sukyol
visited one basement apartment that was
flooded and where three people died the
response from seoul city has been swift
with the government announcing no new
permissions will be given to turn
basements into apartments but there are
reckoned to be around two hundred
thousand homes below ground right now
that authorities say will gradually be
phased out the government has also
announced plans for better drainage
adapting it says to the new reality that
such extreme weather is now no longer
abnormal
rob mcbride al jazeera seoul